le dossier du jour se penche aujourd'hui
sur ce métier dont on dit parfois qu'il
est le plus beau du monde ça veut pas
dire qu'il est le plus facile
les professeurs des écoles doivent
souvent faire face à des classes trop
chargées et se plaignent parfois d'un
certain manque de considération
illustration le temps de cette rencontre
avec emilie elle est institutrice en
maternelle à bèze en côte-d'or mylvada
mois romani pose la journée des mails y
commence à 7h30 chaque matin et au fath
course pour préparer la salle
l'an dernier l'école de bèze comptait
deux classes de maternelle
désormais il n'y en a plus qu'une et
elle est la seule institutrice pour 29,4
plomb façon copiera souffrir de ça pour
faire face emilie a obtenu du renfort
charlène l'atsem et kimberley service
civique l'aide à préparer les ateliers
pédagogiques déjà 8h45 et la cavalerie
fait son entrée
la coupure le rythme va changer et le
niveau sonore aussi par an ces photos
quand les ateliers sont lancés sager
sager en fonction ont fait des besoins
des enfants ils viennent souvent nous
voir nous interrompre avec un atelier où
des ateliers retenus comme ça en fait sa
demande de beaucoup de patience
individualisation est ce qui peut
expliquer aux autres comment tu
réfléchis tu sais pas trop emilie ne
peut pas ménagé ses efforts elle
enseigne à trois niveaux
les petits les moyens et les grands
façonné les esprits de demain c'était
son rêve c'est devenu une grosse
responsabilité
le moins facile je dirai au quotidien
c'est
la pression qu'on peut ressentir sur le
résultat on attend
et puis leur état qui est attendu de
nous il ya la double pression et à la
pression extérieure qui vient aussi bien
des parents de notre hiérarchie mais ici
je crois que c'est la plus forte la
pression que l'on se met nous mêmes par
rapport à trop envie de faire et de
proposer aux enfants pour qu'ils se
sentent bien en classe et qu'ils
apprennent ce tifo en fonction de ce qui
nous est demandé par les instants une
sollicitation constante pour enseigner
régler les conflits ou et yannick
comment tient chronique mais aussi gérer
les pauses pipi ou répondre aux milliers
de questions et ça continue
même pendant la récréation les enfants
sont boursiers en maternelle mans il n'y
a pas vraiment de postes pourraient être
en surveillant tous deux partie du
métier qui a plus de risque d'accident à
l'arrestation des verts au niveau aa
accédants physique
par contre
la tension est quand même pas la même ce
n'est pas un retour en classe changement
d'ambiance et d'activités la sa la
lecture pour faire retomber l'euphorie
de la récré et focaliser leur attention
au secours terminée avant même le
déjeuner et millet l'institutrice aura
été tour à tour animatrice surveillants
intendant et parfois maman un travail
multi fonctions qu'elle n'échangerait
pour rien au monde et qu'elle espère
continuer à exercer dans de bonnes
conditions dès la rentrée prochaine
l'école deviendra obligatoire pour tous
les enfants dès la première section de
maternelle